[Musik]
und ich habe es eben angekündigt jetzt
ist er bei uns im Studio der ehemalige
Nato-General Egon Rams guten Morgen
schön dass Sie sich die Zeit nehmen und
schönen guten Morgen Herr Rams wir haben
es gerade im Beitrag gesehen heftige
Kämpfe um die Städte solida und bachmut
die einen sagen diese Kämpfe haben eine
strategische wichtige Bedeutung für den
Kriegsverlauf andere sagen das ist eher
politisch wichtig wie schätzen sie sind
ein
also ich sehe beides ich sehe die
militärische Bedeutung vor allen Dingen
unter dem Hintergrund oder vor dem
Hintergrund dass die Ukrainer ja im
Prinzip vom Sommer an und in den Herbst
hinein bis in den Winter sowohl im Osten
von chakiff als auch unten im Süden
Person entsprechende militärische
Erfolge erzielt haben viel Gelände
zurückerobert haben und wir sind bei
bachmund und Sonne da sind im Augenblick
einer Situation wo es sich abzeichnet
das ist zur Zeit zumindest
einstellungskrieg dort gibt zwischen den
beiden Seiten aus gut befestigten
Stellung der Ukrainer und dass die
russische Seite insbesondere die Gruppe
Wagner versucht diese Stellung zu
erobern auf diese Art und Weise die
beiden Städte zu bekommen
das würde ihnen eine Pforte wieder nach
Westen eröffnen auch Richtung Archiv
nach Nordwesten aber möglicherweise auch
weiter Richtung Kiew ähm ihre
Korrespondentin hat gerade gesagt das
ist das Ziel der Russen sei den gesamt
zu bekommen und zu erobern und Kontrolle
zu bekommen
auf strategische Ziel der Russen lautet
anders strategische Ziel aus dem
Dezember des Jahres 2021 ist die gesamte
Ukraine und ich glaube nicht und habe
keine Anzeichen dafür dass die russische
Seite dieses Ziel aufgegeben hat und sie
wird möglicherweise als ein Zwischenziel
den gesamten dornbas aber auch die
anderen
Oblaste die sie im Prinzip ja annektiert
haben oder nach Russland aufgenommen
haben versuchen wieder in den Besitz zu
bekommen auf diese Art und Weise zu
zeigen dass Russland in diesem Krieg
weiterhin Einfluss nimmt und Russland
die Chance hat diesen Krieg nach wie vor
mit Zwischenziel zu gewinnen das ist für
Russland ausgesprochen wichtig denn
russland steht im Augenblick etwas ich
sag mal in die Ecke gedrängt da auch mit
Blick auf die eigene Politik in die Ecke
gedrängt weil halt das Ziel was Booten
sich ursprünglich mal gesetzt hat auch
in relativ kurzer Zeit bisher nicht
erreicht worden ist vor dem Hintergrund
her haben sie auch die Entscheidung von
gestern zu sehen dass der Kreml seinen
Kommandeur der russischen Truppen in der
Ukraine erneut ausgetauscht hat also ja
ich glaube dass man diese Frage wirklich
eindeutig mit Ja beantworten kann
einfach weil der Ukraine Krieg aus
russischer Sicht einen Verlauf genommen
hat der von der russischen Seite ja
nicht akzeptabel ist und der auch für
die russische Perzeption sowohl mit
Blick auf Handeln nach außen als auch
Handeln gegenüber der eigenen
Bevölkerung eine ausgesprochen schlechte
Situation geschaffen hat bei den vielen
Toten die wir gehabt haben am
Neujahrstag beispielsweise haben wir die
ersten Demonstrationen in Russland
gehabt das heißt es gibt dort Reaktion
die russische Bevölkerung obwohl
sicherlich auch propagandistische
entsprechend eingefärbt nimmt aber diese
Verluste in der Ukraine war und zeigt
erste vorsichtige Reaktionen das
formuliere ich bewusst so zurückhaltend
weil es schwierig ist diese
innenpolitische Lage in in Russland
einzuschätzen aber es hat eine Bedeutung
nach innen und außen jetzt könntest du
Ukraine den Hosen ja noch schwerer
machen wenn Sie beispielsweise und das
wird ja viel diskutiert dieser Tage neue
Waffen geliefert bekäme dafür hat sich
gestern beispielsweise auch
nato-generalse verkehrsdoltenberg noch
mal nachdrücklicher stark gemacht und
ausgesprochen warum tun sich aus ihrer
Einschätzung die Verbündeten so schwer
da Fakten zu schaffen gerade
rüber läuft glaube ich in diese Richtung
wobei ich schon den Begriff schwere
Waffen für falsch halt die schwerste
Waffe für mich die da ist es die
panzerhaube zu 2000 und die
wirkungsvollste der amerikanische
Raketenwerfer einmaß also von daher das
würde ich dann andere Kategorien
einteilen aber diese Diskussion ist in
diese Richtung gegangen mit Blick auf
Kampfpanzer und Schützenpanzer die
Schützenpanzer Entscheidung ist letzte
Woche gefallen vielleicht durch den ich
sag mal mauerbrecher macron mit seinem x
10 wobei der IMX sind ja kein
Schützenpanzer ist aber auch die
Entscheidung von Joe beiden beträglich
Schützenpanzer zu liefern dem
Deutschland sich da angeschlossen hat
aber ich möchte diese Gelegenheit nutzen
vielleicht noch mal einen kleinen
Hinweis zu geben
die Entscheidung der Schützenpanzer
geliefert werden heißt ja nicht dass die
Schützenpanzer jetzt in der Ukraine sind
sondern wir reden jetzt möglicherweise
über Wochen und Monate mit Ausbildung
mit Transport mit Verlegung mit den
Instandsetzung und dergleichen mir das
heißt diese Waffen sind ja nicht morgen
für die Ukraine verfügbar und das macht
die Situation für die Kreide Ukraine
noch schwieriger zurück unserer Frage
Stichwort Kampfpanzer ich glaube dass
wir Deutschlands haben in eine falsche
Diskussion ziehen lassen weil wir
ausschließlich die Forderung der Ukraine
relativ späte Forderung der Ukraine nach
dem Kampfpanzer Leopard 2 aufgenommen
haben und diesen diskutieren wir in
Deutschland hätten auch andere
Möglichkeiten mit mehr als 100 Leopard
eins die sich bei der Industrie befinden
aus dem damals neusten Baulos des
Leopard 1 mit einer guten Waffenanlage
einer guten Feuerleitanlage mit einer
guten Durchschlagskraft von daher
Diskussionen die falsche Richtung
möglicherweise aber diese Entscheidung
muss fallen und ich denke mal gehe mal
davon aus dass auch nach den
hermannenden Worten von
Generalsekretär Stoltenberg man sich mit
diesem Thema bei dem Treffen der
ukraine-gruppe am 20 Januar in Ramstein
intensiv beschäftigen wird das
beobachten wir natürlich bei Phoenix
dann auch wie das ausgeht Herr Rams viel
geredet und spekuliert wird ja auch über
einen möglichen Kriegseintritt von
Belarus wie würde das den Krieg
verändern
das würde ihn verändern da steht ohne
Zweifel weil damit frische Truppen in
das Gefecht oder in die Operation
eingeführt würden aber ich sehe das noch
nicht so ich habe den Eindruck dass ich
Lukaschenko in Weißrussland als
Präsident dort wenn auch Vasall von
Russland sehr geschickt verhält und zwar
den Russen Basen gibt Übungsplätze gibt
mit denen gemeinsame Übungen durchführt
wie auch jetzt wieder und dergleichen
mehr dass er offensichtlich kein
Interesse daran hat weißrussische
Soldaten über die Grenze in Richtung
Ukraine zu schicken das hat er bisher
sauber von Linien in den vergangenen
mehr als 10 Monaten hat kein
weißrussischer Soldat die Grenze
überschritten von daher sage ich mal
hält er sich da sauber zurück und ich
halte das für geschickt die Politik ich
glaube man sollte diesen Mann mit Blick
auf seine Schlitzohrigkeit nicht
unterschätzen laut der Krieg fast ein
Jahr an in der Ukraine ich muss ihn zum
Abschluss diese Glaskugel Frage noch
stellen wann endet er denn und was muss
passieren welches Szenario ist da
denkbar damit er endet
oder die Situation die wir im Augenblick
haben erlaubt weder Verhandlungen noch
ein Friedensschluss so es geht jetzt
hier und da ist Militär und da ist Krieg
auch ein Mittel der Politik in diesem
Falle darum eine Situation zu schaffen
aus der heraus die Ukraine tatsächlich
in Verhandlung eintreten kann ich muss
noch mal in aller Deutlichkeit sagen
dass entscheidet nicht Europa das
entscheidet nicht die NATO nicht der
amerikanische Präsident sondern das
entscheidet die Ukraine selber an dieser
Zeitpunkt gekommen ist aber auch einen
solchen Zeitpunkt zu erreichen überhaupt
eine Chance zu haben dahin zu kommen
sind die Waffenlieferung an die Ukraine
die Unterstützung der Ukraine in jeder
Hinsicht zwingend erforderlich einfach
aus dem Grund zwingend erforderlich weil
wenn wir die Ukraine nicht unterstützen
wird sie diesen Krieg verlieren und das
ist etwas was auch nicht in unserem
Interesse liegt in keiner Weise denn ich
bin der Meinung und vertrete die auch
offen dass auch unsere Freiheit unsere
Rechtsstaatlichkeit und unsere
Demokratie in der Ukraine durch
ukrainische Soldaten verteidigt wird und
den sollten wir alles geben was sie
brauchen Einschätzungen waren das zum
aktuellen Kriegsgeschehen in der Ukraine
von Egon Rams ehemaliger nato-